I want to bring you up to speed.
In Atlanta, based
grand jury indicted former President
Donald Trump on state charges
stemming from his efforts
to overturn Joe Biden's victory
over him
in the November 2020 election in Georgia.
This is historic.
This is the fourth time
Donald Trump has been indicted.
Let me bring in Kaitlan Collins
right now.
Caitlin,
I'm not sure if you have the indictment
unsealed escape.
This is Caitlin there.
And tell us
what who what is in this indictment?
Is it just Donald Trump
or are there other individuals?
It's of other individuals.
Obviously, it's a 98 page
indictment is going to take us
a minute to read through.
But Jake,
one of the most important parts,
of course, is not just Trump's
name is on this, but it's the others
that are on this.
And so we've got Donald John Trump,
Rudy Giuliani, John Eastman, Mark
Meadows is on here.
Jake, can cheese borrow?
That's another unindicted coconspirator
in the previous indictment.
Jeffrey Clarke
that's the former
Justice Department official
that wanted to be named
the acting attorney general, nearly did.
Jenna Ellis, the Trump attorney.
Ray Smith, another attorney
Robert Chilly, Mike Roman.
That's the Trump
campaign official
who is handling fake electors
in that time period.
Jake, from the election
to third December,
He's someone who's also been part of the
he had met with investigators
in Smith's investigation.
His name is on here.
And David James Schaffer.
That I believe is the top former
Republican official.
He was in a campaign fundraising role
that is also part of this
and was someone who is part of that fake
elector scheme involved in that.
And so those are the names
that I'm reading off this sheet right now
that we see several different charges.
We're waiting to see
which ones, of course, apply
to to which people.
But I mean, the first name
that stood out to me,
a lot of them are obvious.
But Mark Meadows being on there
obviously is fascinating. Yeah. Because
we have this White House chief of staff.
And one of the things
that's interesting about that
is that there was no suggestion
in the federal indictment of Donald Trump
and six unnamed coconspirators,
four of whom at least
are in this indictment as well, and named
that Giuliani
Eastman Cheese Bro and Clark.
But Marc Short,
Vice President Pence's
chief of staff, told me that Mark
Meadows, Trump's
chief of staff
for the White House,
was the ringleader
of the whole conspiracy, and he suspect
that because Meadows
was not a coconspirator
in the federal indictment,
that he was cooperating.
So it is interesting indeed,
that Mark Meadows
is indicted in this state indictment.
Yeah.
And he was the one who with Georgia
in particular, Jake,
he was the one who went down
He was making phone calls to Georgia
officials.
He was the one who went down to Georgia
to visit an audit,
an election audit site.
He was the one who
was on the phone
when Trump called Brad Raffensperger.
And that infamous call
just a few days before January six.
He was actually in the room with Trump,
but he was listening
in another room when the White House
switchboard called him in.
He is someone that Georgia officials,
when you talk to them,
they they echo what Marc Short told you.
They say that he is someone
who was arranging a lot of the calls,
a big part of this.
He is someone who fought
testifying in this, as did others,
when they were
initially investigating this over
the last two and a half years.
So it's just really notable
to see to see his name in here,
to see other Trump campaign
officials, people
like Mike
Roman, who's not a household name,
but he is someone who is working on day
to day
parts and emailing out
about the fake electors.
One other thing about this,
because this is a breaking news story,
and I think you saw the
first page of of the 98 page,
there are actually
nine other individuals
or eight other individuals.
19 total,
I believe, including Donald Trump.
So just the full list.
All right.
Including the list. Yeah.
What you
what you gave us was not the full list
is another page.
But so I'll just going to go
through the whole page. Again.
President Trump,
obviously, Rudy Giuliani,
John Eastman,
the attorney,
Mark Meadows, the former White House
chief of staff,
Kenneth Cheez, bro, the Wisconsin air
campaign lawyer.
The Wisconsin political operative.
Yes, that's right.
A Wisconsin
political operative named Cheese Bro.
Jeff Clarke, the former
Justice Department official.
Jenna Ellis,
former Republican National Committee
lawyer, Ray Smith, Robert
Shealy, Mike Roman and David Schaffer,
all of whom you mentioned before,
Next page, Sean
Michaels, pressure still,
Stephen Cliff, Jared Lee Harrison,
William Prescott, Floyd
Treveon Cudi, for cutting.
I apologize.
Sidney Powell.
Sidney Powell,
who Donald Trump himself
referred to behind closed doors as crazy
with her conspiracy theories
Kathleen Latham, Scott Hall
and Misty Hampton, a.k.a.
Emily, Misty, Haze.
Do you know who that is? She was.
She's actually a very interesting one.
She's not a name
that most people recognize.
She was the Coffee County
election supervisor.
So that story that CNN broke yesterday
about those efforts
to access voting machines
and voting
software in Coffee County, Georgia,
she is someone who played a role in that.
And I believe, Jake
if memory is serving me
right, that Mark Meadows,
when he actually he went down to Georgia,
he met Mr.
Hampton or somehow got her number
and went back to the White House with it.
And that was someone
that they were on the phone
with very quickly after that,
obviously trying to get access
to the voting software and coffee.
Yeah. When Meadows went down to Georgia.